so we went to Berlin yes with you we did
and well I mean you really kind of took
us to Berlin well you know yes a little
bit I invited show us your Berlin I
showed you my Berlin uh on other items
as well
reference to my testicles yes yes and
penis yes I've never yeah I didn't look
I want that to be clear I didn't look
out of respect thank you I did just
because lighting is important to me
Shadows I want to make sure everything
was properly yes like one of the
Renaissance I saw you noticed like flula
has a third leg and then you looked up
you're like oh no you're merely a shadow
there are a lot of peni on that beach oh
we went to a nude beach it was mostly
peanut I didn't see as many naked women
yeah vagina
is is that the norm with with nude
beaches like this or preponderance of
males more penis and yeah I think I
think so it's probably most are sausage
parties right I would think yes yes
schnitzel as well if we're when in
Germany it's a bratwurst party but yeah
yes yes so yeah more part for us than I
don't know whatever we're saying no yes
pretzels the pretzels yes the folded
pretzels
yeah yes let's see if things work out
hey whoa uh things did not work out
that was the narrator yeah yes I took
you I invited Conan when I met him and
you guys are the first time on the show
I would very much like to go to Germany
maybe maybe I could come to Germany with
you I will join you and you will join me
we would be like a three-legged sack
race but with no sack and it's not a
race we will take our time
I just thought I would say it yeah you
didn't think anyone would follow up on
that no oh this was the first and last
time I would ever speak with Conan
O'Brien that was my I was convinced yes
yeah because you you would probably
invited a lot of other people to Germany
everyone all the time yeah that's your
your Ploy yeah smart you never know he's
gonna take up that's my icebreak you
know that's how I do it come with me to
Dusseldorf and no one and and you're
it's sort of a game of chicken because
you're like well I at least got the
credit for offering and they're not
going to take me up and then no one
feeds me chicken yes that's good yeah
you hope that's how you played yeah yeah
but right on the air he was like yeah
I'd love to go with you it was an
instant match it was a deep match yes it
was a big bang we both swiped the
correct direction yes yes and then you
joined as well it was very fun we both
got to go that was one of my favorite
trips
of the one of the travel shows we've
done so far yes I loved going to Berlin
Berlin is a really fun city there's so
much going on oh I agree there's really
cool people yeah delicious food yeah
angular haircuts yes well yeah so we did
a we did a shoe plotler remote and I
think I didn't realize at the time but
you grew up doing shoe plotler correct
yes and that's a dance a cultural dance
a cultural dance sure yeah yeah describe
yeah it's like uh The Running Man of
early Bavaria oh and so except this less
running more hopping uh lots of slapping
hands in the air like you just don't
care and then you slap both knees and
buttocks and just sometimes slap your
feet Yes like a hacky sack hakisaki yes
you may touch other people's uh if I
mean be careful to not hit the penile or
the vagina but you can hit in those
General regions as well yeah and then
lots of polkamu's music is playing
[Applause]
all right
okay what do you wear for that anything
you like but also only leader hose okay
is that why because Lederhosen seem like
they might be a little bit protective in
the crotch area because it's it's
leather it's stiff leather you mean like
there's a condom built in well I guess I
mean that that seems like the right
clothing to wear if you're gonna get
slapped on the on the crotch yes of
course yes if you hit a cow's hide
versus if you hit a nylon yes one will
hurt and Bruise Your Clementines and the
other one will protect those the shock
absorber that's correct yes yes yes yes
yes yes so sort of safety safety first
that's how we do it this is how we do it
Montel Jordan hello dude so is there a
limited shelf life or shoot plot like do
they get you like your brain injuries
you're asking is there like a Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar that played 20 seasons of
shoe plattler everyone else is like
three to five years Emmitt Smith's
running back yes before you become
sterile
yes steal everyone they're such poachers
The Bling blancs yeah yeah there's an
omelette somewhere no one tells you
where we invite you to guess the
umlab is coming from inside the building
that's correct yes
just going back to inviting Conan oh
sure uh did you really think
that was going to happen of course not
no no I truly did think I would be
escort at the middle of the taping away
from the show before making no sense and
then referencing stacked with a
restraining order immediately slept
somewhere with something yes of course
and had you spent a lot of time I know
you're obviously from Germany had you
spent a lot of time specifically in
Berlin the wonderful thing is I don't
know Berlin at all uh this is it's like
if you ask a man from Tulsa to then say
hey show me Manhattan right right right
what okay I don't know the Met which one
the baseball team nobody knows it's a
chance to study up I Googled it yes yeah
okay yeah yeah just like a good tutor be
one chapter ahead of the student
exactly that's all I was yeah but it was
fun I can speak the language and no one
else could be well I can bail you know
we know I have limitations you know just
as a human person but I was able to
communicate yeah definitely